ADULTS THAT ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
PASS A BACKGROUND CHECK, WHAT
COULD GO WRONG.
OUR SHELTERS AND IMMIGRATION
FACILITIES ARE OVERRUN, AND IF
FIVE TITLE 40 TO EXPIRES THIS
WEEK, AND REMEMBER THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION THEY WANT IT TO
EXPIRE THEY WANT IT GONE.
THE TOOL OUT OF THE TOOLBOX, TH
FLOW OF ILLEGALS WILL SURGE TO
14,000 EVERY SINGLE DAY IF NOT
MORE.
HERE WITH MORE ON THIS CRISIS
LIVE IN LA JOLLA TAXES, SARAH
CARTER, YOU HAVE DONE GREAT
REPORTING THROUGHOUT, WHAT DO
YOU HAVE TONIGHT?
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH, SEVERAL
HOURS AGO, THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ACTUALLY SUBMITTED TO
THE SUPREME COURT AND APPEALED
TO BASICALLY EXTEND TITLE 42 FO
PROBABLY JUST A WEEK OR SO TO
GIVE THE WHITE HOUSE JUST ENOUG
TIME TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO WITH THIS BORDER
CHAOS I CAN TELL YOU THIS THAT
WHILE THEY ARE DEBATING ON HOW
TO HANDLE THE U.S. MEXICAN
BORDER AND THE MILLIONS THAT AR
GOING TO COME POURING ACROSS, I
IS THE PEOPLE HERE IN McALLEN,
TEXAS, IN LA JOLLA AND ALL ALON
THE BORDER, THAT REALLY HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE ENORMOUS AMOUNT O
PEOPLE AND STRAIN ON THE
RESOURCES.
WE WERE OUT EARLY TODAY WITH TH
TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY AS WELL AS BORDER PATROL
AS PEOPLE WERE BAILING OUT OF
VEHICLES IN RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOODS LITERALLY, JUMPIN
OVER FENCES INTO GATED
COMMUNITIES, THEY WERE RUNNING
BEHIND THEIR HOMES AND SOME PAC
PLACES I LIVED IN AS PEOPLE WER
EATING BREAKFAST AS THEY WERE
SEARCHING FOR RUNNERS BEHIND TH
HOUSES, IT IS EXTRAORDINARILY
FRUSTRATING NOT ONLY FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT BUT THE PEOPLE AND
THESE COMMUNITIES, WE ALSO
ATTENDED TODAY AT TOWN HALL
MEETING WITH BOTH DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS ALIKE, BOTH
WONDERING WHEN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WAS GOING TO DO ITS
JOB TO PROTECT THE BORDER I HAD
A CHANCE TO SPEAK WITH CONGRESS
WHEN IT MONICA de LA CRUZ AND
SHE IS EXTRAORDINARILY
FRUSTRATED, SHE SAID THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN EFFORT THAT PEOPLE I
HER COMMUNITY ARE ANGRY AND THE
WANT CHANGES AND THEY WANT IT
NOW TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT SHE
HAD TO SAY.
>> WHO IS BENEFITING FOR HAVING
NO REGULATIONS ON THE BORDER,
THE ONLY ONE REGULATING IS THE
CARTEL, THEY ARE CHARGING THESE
IMMIGRANTS TEN, 15, $20,000 TO
BRING THEM THROUGH THE SOUTHERN
BORDER THEY ARE ALSO BENEFITING
BECAUSE OF THE AMOUNT OF DRUGS
THEY CAN PASS THROUGH OUR
BORDERS.
THE ONLY PERSON OR PERSONS WHO
ARE WINNING ARE THE CARTEL.
WHY DOES IT APPEAR THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS SUPPORTING TH
CARTEL IN THE TRAFFICKERS?
HAVE YOU BROUGHT THIS UP TO THE
WHITE HOUSE?
HAVE YOU SAID WAIT A MINUTE, WE
MIGHT DISAGREE ON A FEW THINGS,
BUT I THINK WE CAN AGREE ON THIS
.
WE OBVIOUSLY DON'T AGREE ON A
LOT OF THINGS, ONE BEING THAT I
BELIEVE WE NEED TO PUT THESE
POLICIES OF STOPPING IN MEXICO
AND PLACE.
TITLE 42 NEEDS TO CONTINUE UNTI
WE HAVE THE IMMIGRATION REFORM
AND LEGISLATION WHERE WE CAN
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS AND HAVE
IMMIGRANTS WAIT IN MEXICO OR GO
TO SAVE COUNTRIES WHERE THEY CA
APPLY FOR THE ASYLUM PROCESS.
>> WHAT WOULD YOUR MESSAGE BE T
PRESIDENT BIDEN RIGHT NOW ABOUT
HOW URGENT A CRISIS THIS IS AND
WHAT HE NEEDS TO DO TO STOP IT?
>> I INVITE PRESIDENT BIDEN TO
COME DOWN TO SOUTH TEXAS AND SE
WITH HIS OWN EYES WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
TO TALK TO THESE BRAVE MEN AND
WOMEN AND BORDER CONTROL AND
CUSTOMS WHO ARE AT THE FRONT
LINES AND SEEING THIS.
WHAT IS ABOUT TO HAPPEN WHEN
TITLE 42 IS LIFTED WILL BE A
CATASTROPHE OF EPIC PROPORTIONS.
>> IT IS A CATASTROPHE RIGHT
ACROSS THE BORDER IN MEXICO,
THERE ARE NOW JUST RIGHT HERE,
SEVERAL MILES FROM US MORE THAN
10,000 PEOPLE THAT OUR WAITING
TO MAKE A MOVE ACROSS THE BORDE
AND UNDER TITLE 42.
MAINLY CHILDREN, THESE WE'RE
ILLEGAL MIGRANTS THAT CROSSED
OVER, WE HAVE ONE BORDER PATROL
AGENT TRYING TO PROCESS ALL OF
THEM.
THERE IS A BUZZ HERE, IT IS
FILLED WITH THE MIGRANTS.
HE TRAVELED WITH HER TEENAGE
BROTHER ALL THE WAY FROM EL
SALVADOR.
IT WAS VERY HARROWING JOURNEY.
I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU.
WHEN YOU REALIZE HOW ABUSED THE
ARE ON THIS JOURNEY TO THE
UNITED STATES.
I ASKED THEM WHY DID YOU TELL
THAT PEOPLE WHERE HE COMING THI
WAY.
YOUR SO YOUNG, WEREN'T YOU
AFRAID, SHE SAID YES, BUT I
HAVEN'T SEEN MY MOTHER IN FIVE
YEARS AND I WANT TO FIND MY
FAMILY.
A LOT OF TIMES THESE CHILDREN
ARE ABUSED, IN SOMETIMES LIKE
YOU SAID AND REPORTED EARLIER,
THEY ARE WITH ABUSERS.
I CAN'T GET THEM TO TALK ABOUT
EVERYTHING, BUT IT WAS REALLY
TRAGIC SITUATION HERE ALONG THE
BORDER.
>> SARAH, I CAN'T HELP BUT THIN
SEEING YOUR FAMILY IS ADMIRABLE
BUT IT'S NOT A QUALIFICATION FO
ASYLUM WHICH IS WHAT MAKES IT
ILLEGAL.
AND,.
>> WRITES.
>> THAT IS WHERE THE ABUSE OF
THE SYSTEM COMES IN AND WHERE
THE TENS OF THOUSANDS ARE HEADED
.
>> AND MANY TIMES, THESE
CHILDREN ARE TRAINED TO SAY THI
STORY THE WAY THAT THEY SAY IT,
MANY TIMES THEY ARE WITH PEOPLE
THAT HAVE TRAVELED WITH THEM
THAT HAVE PREPARED THEM TO ENTE
THE COUNTRY THIS WAY AND JUST
LIKE YOU REPORTED LAST NIGHT, A
LOT OF THESE CHILDREN ARE ABUSE
ONCE THEY ENTER THE UNITED
STATES.
WE HONESTLY DO NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO HANDLE THIS AND
THIS IS WHY YOU ARE SEEING THE
BREAKDOWN IN OUR SYSTEM IN A
BREAKDOWN AT THE BORDER.
BY THIS WEEKEND THE TEMPERATURE
WILL DROP INTO THE LOW 20s AND
THEY ARE EXPECTING DANGEROUS
SITUATIONS, SO THEY ARE
EXPECTING QUITE A FEW PEOPLE TO
TRY IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF NIGHTS
, BUT THEY ARE ALSO VERY
CONSULT CONCERNED THAT SOME
CHILDREN AND OTHER ADULTS MAY
LOSE THEIR LIFE IN THEIR ATTEMP
TO TRY TO COME INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
>> CARTELS, AND LIES AND